so no i know i've not been uh putting
trash taste on the best of records
recently you know we've uh put the
streams uh we've delayed the streams two
weeks because uh i unfortunately got
covered and now we've had to delay the
stream for two days now
because i got stuck in a snowstorm
because i was up in hokkaido i can't get
a dump
i am playing gatron life and i am losing
on every [ __ ] role i swear to god
um but no that's exactly how it felt
because i was up in uh i was up in
hokkaido just just on a trip just on a
trip with me in sydney for like a good
like four or five days yeah and we were
scheduled to come back on the monday
yeah and if anything happened on the
monday i could have come back tuesday
morning to record trash taste because my
entire life is planned around trash
today's recordings i'm sure you'll you
guys are live streams now
um and unfortunately on
on monday i woke up and checked my
flight my flight was cancelled i was
like all right whatever it's hokkaido we
can expect that to happen sometimes um i
look on the site to rebook my flight
and every single flight for the entire
day is just council council council
council council council cancelled um so
how bad was the storm it was really
really [ __ ] bad it was like
i've obviously not had much experience
in like cold weather and snow yeah so
this was the first time
this was the first time i'd ever been
like i guess caught in a snowstorm and i
remember
um i remember that when like during the
snowstorm we had to take a taxi to the
airport because um all of the trains had
stopped running so it wasn't just planes
we were looking at oh can we take you
know the shinkansen or the train back
from hokkaido to tokyo nope everything
everything was gone which says a lot
with hokkaido right because like
hokkaido is one of those places where it
snows so often yeah even like just like
a little bit of snow or like a
substantial amount of snow it's still
like yeah we'll just power through it
yeah unlike tokyo where it's like 10
centimeters of snow stop the trains stop
everything bro the uk can't imagine man
the uk can't imagine right i remember we
we like constantly go through grit
shortages in the uk because we're just
so ill prepared for just the tiniest bit
of snow they always do this the exact
same speech every time
they were like why aren't the buses
running the buses were running during
world war ii and now they've stopped
because of a bit of snow what is this
they do every single time right yes they
say how dare the buses stop the absolute
state it's like what what because
another country attacks or because
nature attacks what do you think is
scarier nature
definitely yeah so i remember like i
remember during the snowstorm um i had
to go outside for just a few seconds um
to go to to go from my hotel front door
to the taxi in the road in front of me a
simple one to two minute walk you know
ev we've all done it and i remember
thinking it's just a bit of snow it's
just a bit of wind i've handled that
before i go out and then i've never felt
like nature has just like beaten the
[ __ ] out of me just as soon as i stepped
out the door right
because like this snow i'm like i've
felt snow before it's like it's you know
i felt snow before it's soft it's fluffy
it's soft it's fluffy no this snow was
like [ __ ] ice man yeah like the wind
had turned this soft fluffy snow into
like an
into like a [ __ ] wmd or something
like that
like my face literally like i felt like
my face was like getting cut from like
the brief moment that i didn't have my
hood up you look like the weekend album
yeah yeah
yeah and so and seeing a caught in like
a pokemon attack yeah yeah basically it
like this was literally just blizzard
i could feel like the hail just like
[ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of my face
that 120 powerpoint dude
oh like and it was even worse for sydney
as well because for some reason uh
sydney decided that she shouldn't bring
any footwear to hokkaido other than
heels so i mean it was like it was like
boots right but it was like boots with
like heels on them yeah
um that's uh like yeah i i know i know
i know you know
what was she expecting up in hokkaido
i think it's just been so long since
she's seen snow right that she has
forgotten what you know other
well other environments it's like
wisconsin right doesn't it snow like a
[ __ ] up always yeah it does it
does because i was i was just like i
remember asking her oh i remember
telling her oh i've never seen like snow
like this in my life and she was like oh
it's uh it's been a long time and i was
like so it's been a long time for you
and yet you were still so
you're less prepared you're so prepared
for this weather
um but yeah i mean we just weren't
obviously we weren't expecting it to uh
be that harsh yeah the weather
conditions would be that hard so hard um
and yeah we had to stay in hokkaido
basically we were living out of an
airport hotel for two days uh because we
woke up the next day uh we i remember
because i messaged these guys uh guys
we're gonna have to possibly delay the
recording by like an hour or two maybe
i'm gonna get an early flight it's all
gonna be good it's only like the weather
forecast it's only scheduled for the
snow to be really bad on this day i wake
up i look out my window uh the
blizzard's still [ __ ] going
and i'm like guys so guys okay we okay i
can make it back i swear to god i can
make it back the flight's on cancel yeah
the flight sign canceled here and i
remember like trying to like reorganize
with these guys to be like okay i'm
gonna make it back on this hour i can
make back of this to the studio at this
hour we can record we can still stream
it's all good it's all good it's fixed
guys we can still do trash taste um an
hour passes and then every flight is
canceled again
and in in the
the defeated manner i text this boys guy
i'm going like sorry boys i'll let you
down i'll let you down boys i'll let you
down it wasn't so much you that let us
down it was the [ __ ] weather yeah
like it wasn't your fault
yeah and just fight through it yeah just
walk back just walk back it's walkable
yeah cause like because like we've been
through hokkaido like a few times before
yeah and like i swear to god they just
like like sweating every time you go to
hokkaido you're playing gacha with the
planes
right because a lot of planes get
cancelled like very frequently right
obviously not as not in this kind of
state where like literally the entire
airport was shut down but you're
normally playing gacha when you go to
hokkaido because one or two planes will
normally get cancelled or rescheduled or
like heavily heavily delayed but then
that's when you discovered why
airport which is the airport in hokkaido
is so well equipped right right yeah
yeah it is actually like chitose airport
is like one of the best airports
i've been to in the world i think just
just i mean just with like how many
restaurants and how many like resources
are there there's basically like a
shopping mall inside the airport yeah
yeah basically because like
because like the airports that stick out
to me are airports like singapore
airport yeah which is just like that's
like an amazing airport like uh the
hokkaido airport is more like that's
that's more like a shopping mall with an
airport attached to it yeah yeah yeah
well most because most of the stuff you
see is before you go into the departure
zone whereas most airports like it's the
departure zone which really has all of
the restaurants all of the shops and all
the everything but yeah in chitosa i
mean there's even like a uh there's even
like a cinema there as well yeah which
uh there were i was yeah yeah yeah i
don't know yeah i mean if you watch
something i didn't the only film they
were playing was uh the jiu jitsu tyson
movie do this just go watch it let's go
watch it i mean i i i am i i am actually
going to go watch it this weekend which
is which is the only reason why i didn't
watch it when i was in hokkaido um
yeah i mean i mean it wasn't it wasn't
too bad because of the airport there
luckily i was able to get an air to get
a hotel at the airport
um it was just more annoying because
obviously i wanted to be back i wanted
to be working
um but yeah i mean that was there's not
there's not really much to say about it
i mean like i'm sure this is like every
other day for a canadian yeah i like i
remember like there's going to be a
million [ __ ] people in the comments
being like
imagine living with sort of that every
day of the week
yeah because i remember you didn't bring
your own slay dogs
yeah it was just weird just like because
i'm just used to no matter what happens
there's always kind of like a plan b
that you can fall back on a possible
plan b um but it was just the roads were
closed airports were closed trains were
closed so i was literally like stranded
you basically experienced quarantine
yeah yeah basically yeah
i was basically stranded at the airport
and there was no plan b there wasn't
there was no services i could call to
get myself out of there to a place where
i could get some public transport to
tokyo because did you go around
getting the shopping carts to get some
money together so you could buy a burger
so yeah i basically just lived the
terminal except